cinéma muet cinéma parlant cinémascope
cinéma en couleurs monsieur pierre
tchernia
seriez vous capable en tant que
candidats de participer à un jeu sur le
cinéma banc d'ailleurs si je pose des
questions à monsieur cinéma c'est
justement parce que je suis incapable
d'y répondre
va qui a trouvé ce titre de monsieur
cinéma c'est lui c'est lui qui trouve
utile
jacques rouland très heureux de vous
rencontrer mon cher jacques rouland
pourquoi la télévision consacrent hôtel
au cinéma une émission chaque lundi sur
la deuxième chaîne a maintenant choisi
veut dire on vous aime pas la question
j'aime pas bon alors changer de caisse
quelle différence y at-il entre l'ancien
jeu 7e art 7e case et le nouveau
monsieur cinéma voici une bonne question
très bonne alma très bonnes c'est la
série harry fait face donc fait été un
peu mou comme vous automne comment
préparez vous les jeux va l'époque déjà
il faut bien le dire parce que sur les
faits dont feraient pas grand chose car
plus paresseux et plus y'a que moi de
plus par écrit puis en france je crois
dans l'original verbe qui les aide
beaucoup
yach enclos de rohmer qui connaît le
cinéma par coeur il a la tête c'est un
fichier après les mains il ya au service
cinéma patrick brion claude nahon
enfin on trouve de l'aide à ces éléments
sont des gens très gentils très sérieux
comment recruter vous les candidats tout
d'abord dans la famille des tirelires
parce que la famille de roulant ils ne
veulent pas venir à la télévision ils
ont peur qu'on les reconnaisse dans leur
quartier ils sont déjà assez repéré pops
mais disons quand même que le jeu est
ouvert à tout le monde
mais comment les recrutez-vous par les
éliminatoires on a fait il ya quelques
jours des éliminatoires on
deux candidats pour l'année n'y a que la
famille algeria kiedis partie
d'éliminatoires lequel de vous choisi
les extraits de films que l'on voit
écoutez je vais vous dire pierre c'est
extrêmement simple tous les bons extrait
me sont imputables et tous les mauvaises
extraits sont en général choisi par ge
oui j'arrive n'y a aucun j'aime pas été
sage absorber le choc n'a pas dit quand
je n'ai aucun goût
moi j'ai beaucoup de goût pas son
camarade et pourquoi avez vous souhaité
bavarder avec des personnalités à la fin
de la projection de grands films c'est
une question de contacts humains de
chaleur humaine nous a semblé qu'il
fallait à travers la classe du petit
écran établir un contact entre le public
et ceux qui font les films mais avez
vous souvent dans les salles obscures
ah oui alors là j'avoue je peux vous
dire le moins rock pour si je voyais les
gens pouvaient aller de lundi 17h à 19h
appelé mercredi à copé